here's the thing you need to know about
witches
they're real they're here and they live
amongst us
witches wear long gloves to their elbows
they don't have
hands they have claws their nostrils are
larger than most
and they all wear wigs and when they
take the wigs off
they're all bald they don't have any
toes
they have elongated mouths that stretch
to their ears
i have a plan they'll transform
okay here's what we do keep your eyes
open stay alert
carry on the fight what has a witch ever
done to you
the witches read the movie premiere at
home october 26th
here's the thing you need to know about
witches they're real
they're here and they live amongst us
witches wear long gloves to their elbows
they don't have
hands they have claws their nostrils are
larger than most
and they all wear wigs and when they
take the wigs off they're all
bald they don't have any toes they have
elongated mouths that stretch to their
ears
i have a plan to transform those brats
into mice okay here's what we do
keep your eyes open stay alert carry on
the
fight what has a witch ever done to you
the witches
read the movie premiere at home october
26th
you